I felt excruciating pain.
Then I blacked out.
Then my brother said,
"I can't feel my feet,"
and I blacked out.
I heard the stewardess
coming and I blacked out.
I'm a huge Harry Potter fan
and my wife surprised
me with a trip to
the local owl preserve.
I remember I was wearing
my Ron Weasley wig and robe.
I stopped to make a pee-pee
behind a tree
and that's when
I first heard them.
"Hoo-hoo."
My brother and I were
floating in a life raft.
We looked around
and we just saw endless ocean
and we knew
we were alone.
We tried to calm each other down
by singing "The Sweater Song."
I looked at my brother
and I said,
"My God, I don't
think anyone is coming."
The first thing I noticed
as I got on the plane
was that they weren't using
zoned seating and I'm platinum.
I should be on there before
those other people.
I should be
boarding zone one.
The owls had begun
to circle around me.
At first, I thought
it was magical.
Then they attacked.
Their beaks were
like razorblades.
I screamed out for help,
but nobody came.
They said my bag
was too big
and they made me check it
like an animal,
which means I had
to hold my MacBook Air,
my Kindle Fire and
my iPad all in my lap,
and then I remembered
I forgot something.
My headphones.
My brother said there
was only one way to survive.
We had to drink each
other's pee.
My brother stood over me,
but the boat was rocky
and most of his pee went
directly into my eyes and hair.
He started laughing
and I got mad.
At the time,
I didn't realize that it'd
be the last time I'd ever
hear my brother laugh.
Then they announced
the in-flight movie.
"Zookeeper,"
with Kevin James.
When I woke up, I saw the
owls were kind of laying around.
And they looked
sort of sleepy and full.
That's when I realized,
my arms were gone.
The owls had eaten
my arms.
And then I pretty much knew
that no one was coming for me.
I'm sorry.
And I see the ranger shack.
All the rangers are
standing outside
and they see me
and they're like,
"Dude, where's your arms?"
And I'm like, "The owls ate
them, I didn't even care,
'cause I was just so happy."
So I'm trying to get
into "Zookeeper,"
'cause I'm a good sport and
I order a glass of chardonnay.
And in a 9/11-like twist,
they didn't have any.
They offered...
...they offered me pinot.
I said, "I don't want
pinot, " I said,
"Please just
give me chardonnay,
I know you guys have it, I know
it's back there.
I'm platinum, like,
I'm ( bleep ) platinum."
I endured because my brother
peed in my mouth.
I endured because
the owls filled up
on arms and didn't save
any room for legs.
I endured because I wanted
to bang my married ex
and I did
and he's divorced now.
Thank you.